- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
Je suis heureuse de souhaiter en
votre nom la bienvenue à une
délégation de l'association
interparlementaire Canada-France.
Bienvenue à vous.
Applaudissements
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première va être posée par
monsieur Olivier Falorni pour le
groupe Démocrate.
- Olivier Falorni: Merci, madame la
présidente.
La Convention citoyenne sur la fin
de vie a répondu dimanche à la
question que vous lui aviez posée le
9 décembre dernier.
A travers 146 propositions, cette
Convention citoyenne a exprimé
clairement et très précisément sa
volonté de voir évoluer notre cadre
légal actuel.
Je tiens ici à saluer le travail
remarquable grâce à l'appui du
conseil économique, social et
environnemental de ces 184 citoyens
tirés au sort et représentatifs de
la diversité de notre société.
184 citoyens de tous âges et de
toutes conditions, qui ont accepté
de consacrer durant 27 journées,
durant 9 sessions, de participer à
une réflexion collective sur ce
sujet majeur.
Ils ont affirmé avec force la
nécessité de renforcer les soins
palliatifs pour tous et partout sur
le territoire.
Ils ont exprimé une demande forte à
une très large majorité que soit
autorisée en France l'aide active à
mourir sous certaines conditions,
comme par exemple la durabilité de
la maladie, le pronostic vital
engagé et les souffrances
réfractaires, ou encore la volonté
réitérée du malade, sans oublier la
clause de conscience des soignants.
Madame la Première ministre, je
souhaitais tout simplement vous
demander quelle suite entendez-vous
donner à ce message fort qui a été
exprimé par cette très belle
Convention citoyenne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Falorni, il y a
peu de sujets plus complexes, plus
délicats que la fin de vie.
Pour que toutes les opinions
puissent s'exprimer et que des
consensus puissent émerger, le
président de la République avait
fait le choix de ne pas trancher le
débat lors de la campagne
électorale, mais de le laisser se
tenir dans la société.
C'est le sens de la Convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie que
j'avais lancée en décembre dernier
avec Agnès Firmin Le Bodo et Olivier
Véran.
Cette convention a permis à toutes
les opinions de s'exprimer.
Assumer des points de convergence et
de consensus, sans passer sous
silence les désaccords.
Comme l'a souligné hier le président
de la République, cette convention a
enrichi nos pratiques démocratiques
et déboucher sur un rapport de
grande qualité qui va nourrir les
débats sur la fin de vie dans les
prochains mois.
En parallèle, d'autres consultations
et travaux ont été menées pour
éclairer le gouvernement, les
parlementaires et le débat public.
Je pense aux débats engagés sous
l'égide du comité consultatif, aux
échanges avec les associations, les
patients et la mission d'évaluation
transpartisane que vous avez
présidée sur la loi Claeys-Leonetti.
Je veux saluer la qualité de vos
analyses et de vos recommandations.
Tous ces travaux ont fait avancer
notre réflexion collective par des
clivages partisans.
Ils ont abouti à deux conclusions
fortes sur lesquelles nous
souhaitons avancer ensemble, comme
l'a annoncé hier le président de la
République.
La première est la nécessité de
renforcer d'urgence l'offre de soins
palliatifs.
Nous allons lancer une stratégie
pour permettre une meilleure prise
en charge de la douleur et l'accès
aux soins palliatifs.
La seconde, c'est la nécessité
d'inventer un modèle français de la
fin de vie.
Notre cadre législatif n'est plus
adapté, notamment pour aborder le
sujet de l'aide à mourir.
Collectivement, nous devons nous
saisir les conclusions de la
Convention citoyenne.
Ensemble, nous construirons un
projet de loi qui sera déposé d'ici
la fin de l'été.
Je souhaite que la préparation de ce
texte associe largement toutes les
forces politiques, mais également
les soignants, les associations et
les représentants des patients.
Face à un sujet aussi grave, nous
avançons avec humanité et humilité.
Nous avons à coeur de bâtir une
réponse qui trouve un soutien très
large dans un esprit de concorde et
de rassemblement.
Nous y parviendrons ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Alain David
pour le groupe Socialiste.
- Alain David: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
En dépit de vos tentatives de
pourrissement, le front syndical
reste solide et les organisations
syndicales du pays restent
mobilisées avec constance et
détermination.
Tandis qu'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation aura lieu jeudi, les
syndicats vous rappellent leur
opposition résolue au passage de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
à 64 ans.
Comme la nouvelle secrétaire
générale de la CGT, Sophie Binet,
dont je salue l'élection, l'a
rappelé: "Le retrait de cette
réforme est la seule solution".
Votre projet est condamné par une
majorité de nos concitoyens, refusé
par les partenaires sociaux et ne
dispose d'aucune majorité politique,
vous conduisant à l'usage du 49.3.
Certains présidents se rendent
aujourd'hui devant le Conseil
constitutionnel afin d'exposer nos
arguments juridiques suite au
recours déposé par une majorité de
députés.
Nous exprimerons toujours notre
mobilisation ici et dans notre
circonscription contre ce projet de
réforme des retraites.
Il est injuste socialement et
inefficace économiquement.
La colère sociale monte et les
préoccupations sur le pouvoir
d'achat devraient inciter le
gouvernement à s'attaquer aux
problèmes quotidiens de nos
concitoyens, plutôt que de braquer
toute la société contre une réforme
inique.
Il vous appartient d'entendre le
message des Françaises et des
Français.
Vous ne pouvez les ignorer plus
longtemps.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Les semaines se suivent et parfois,
se ressemblent.
Vous nous interroger sur la réforme
des retraites.
C'est l'occasion de répéter sa
nécessité pour garantir le système
de répartition, pour garantir la
solidarité intergénérationnelle.
Cette réforme s'est-elle faite à
l'issue d'un débat?
Oui.
Avec les partenaires sociaux, des
convergences ont été faites, malgré
les désaccords.
Il a eu aussi les débats au
Parlement.
Vous dites que vous maintiendrez
votre mobilisation, mais la réalité,
c'est que votre mobilisation est
stérile.
Vous avez joué la carte de
l'obstruction.
Vous n'avez pas bougé.
Vous voulez augmenter les impôts et
les taxes?
Nous, nous prenons nos
responsabilités.
Nous les prenons et nous voulons le
faire à nouveau dans ce débat.
Demain, la Première ministre recevra
l'intersyndicale pour évoquer
ensemble ces sujets.
Monsieur le député, vous savez, à
l'occasion de votre question, vous
avez souligné que le week-end
dernier était un week-end
d'élections.
Je m'associe à vos salutations
auprès de Sophie Binet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Béatrice Descamps.
- Béatrice Descamps: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Personnes handicapées.
Madame la ministre, un amendement
permet de maintenir en établissement
spécialisé les enfants de jeunes
adultes ayant dépassé la limite
d'âge administrative de 20 ans et en
attente de places en structure pour
adultes.
Actuellement, faute de structures
adaptées, beaucoup de ces jeunes
restent jusqu'à 28 ans en IME.
Ils développent un mal-être du
comportement et des absences à
répétition.
L'accueil prolongé de ces personnes
en IME bloque l'accès de ces
établissements aux plus jeunes.
Il y a d'importantes contraintes qui
sont posées aux équipes qui doivent
démultiplier l'offre d'activités
éducatives et de soutiens
médico-sociaux, ainsi que des
difficultés juridiques qui peuvent
engendrer
des problèmes.
Cet amendement ne permet que de
décaler les ruptures de parcours et
le retour à domicile sans
accompagnement.
Les mamans savent que dans quelques
années, il n'y aura pas de réponses
adaptées et j'ai une pensée pour ces
mamans de jeunes autistes que j'ai
reçus récemment.
J'évoque ici les jeunes pour
lesquels les solutions alternatives
ne sont pas envisageables.
Aujourd'hui, il faut rappeler qu'il
faut attendre 10 à 15 ans pour avoir
une place dans un établissement pour
adultes.
Madame la ministre, quelles pistes
comptez-vous suivre pour réduire ces
déséquilibres et apporter des
réponses concrètes à ces familles et
à ces jeunes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Geneviève
Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Béatrice Descamps,
vous posez une question importante
et difficile.
Les adultes en établissement
d'enfants, pour moi, c'est non.
Ils n'ont rien à y faire.
Nous devons être proactifs pour
faire en sorte de changer la
situation.
Changer la situation ne se fera pas
en un jour.
Soyons honnêtes.
Cela se fera en fonction des besoins
de ces personnes.
Certains peuvent rentrer dans
l'emploi, il en existe.
D'autres ne peuvent pas entrer dans
l'emploi mais doivent avoir des
accompagnements spécifiques, voire
des structures spécifiques.
Je souhaite que chaque cas soit
évalué individuellement.
Nous avons devant nous un vrai
travail que la prochaine conférence
nationale du handicap nous permettra
d'étudier.
Il faut les aider plus précocement
dans leurs capacités, leurs
compétences, les mettre en formation
plus précocement, et faire en sorte
de pouvoir avoir un trajet de sortie
de ces IME, les
ESAT, pour les cas les plus
complexes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Claire Guichard pour
le groupe Renaissance.
- Claire Guichard: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la ministre
de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche.
J'y associe certaines de mes
collègues.
Mercredi dernier, vous lanciez la
première étape de la réforme des
retraites.
Pour autant, l'Etat n'a pas attendu
cela pour soutenir et accompagner
les étudiants.
Certains semblent l'avoir oublié,
mais c'est notre majorité qui, en
pleine période de Covid, a mis en
place le repas à 1 euro.
Notre majorité aide ainsi les
étudiants précaires qui en font la
demande.
C'est encore et toujours notre
majorité qui a modifié un barème qui
n'avait pas évolué depuis 10 ans.
Cette réforme, c'est le fruit d'une
concertation engagée depuis octobre
par le gouvernement avec l'ensemble
des organisations représentatives
étudiantes.
Ce sont 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour nos étudiants
dès la rentrée universitaire 2023.
Jamais, en 10 ans, l'Etat n'avait
autant investi pour aider sa
jeunesse.
C'est historique.
Ces nouvelles mesures répondent à
l'objectif fixé par le président de
la République.
Le coût de la vie ne sera plus
jamais une barrière aux études.
Les étudiants issus des classes
moyennes vont être aidées.
Les frais d'inscription seront
gratuits pour tous ceux-là, et ils
ne paieront pas de frais.
Nous aidons les jeunes en augmentant
le montant des bourses pour tous les
échelons à 37 euros.
Nous aidons nos jeunes.
140.000 boursiers actuels vont
basculer dans un échelon de bourse
supérieure.
Cela prend en compte leur situation
familiale.
Ces étudiants sont notre avenir.
Pouvez-vous nous dire comment va
s'organiser la seconde étape de
cette consultation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sylvie Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Claire Guichard,
tout d'abord, merci pour votre
question qui permet de revenir sur
cette réforme des bourses et sur ce
que le gouvernement et
la majorité font pour les étudiants.
En effet, nous avons voulu faire
plus pour les étudiants.
Comme vous l'avez dit, ce sera à la
rentrée 2023.
Ces 35.000 nouveaux boursiers
pourront toucher 145 euros par mois
en plus des avantages que vous avez
cités.
Nous avons voulu faire mieux pour
ces étudiants avec 140.000 boursiers
qui vont changer d'échelon et qui
vont gagner entre 166 euros et 227
euros par mois.
Au minimum, l'ensemble de tous les
étudiants boursiers pourront
bénéficier de ces 37 euros qui
correspondent à une augmentation de
34% pour les plus petits échelons et
de 6% pour les plus hauts échelons.
Je veux revenir sur cette
pérennisation de ce repas à tarif
très social, que cette majorité, ce
gouvernement a mis en place.
Ce repas à 1 euro sera effectivement
pérennisé en plus du repas social à
3,30 euros qui est gelé
avec le CROUS.
Tout cela a été obtenu après une
concertation de plus de six mois
avec les représentants étudiants qui
ont pu reconnaître cette avancée
pour l'ensemble des étudiants.
Cette concertation, je vous
l'annonce, va pouvoir continuer
aussi bien au niveau territorial
qu'au niveau national, sur
l'ensemble de la vie étudiante.
Nous agissons.
Ce gouvernement agit pour les
étudiants.
Cette réforme des bourses pourra
être mise au bénéfice de cette
majorité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Silence, vous gênez les orateurs.
Vous avez la parole, ma chère
collègue?
Je vous demande le silence, s'il
vous plaît.
Merci de le respecter.
Merci.
La parole est à Sandra Regol.
- Sandra Regol: 229%, C'est
l'augmentation des bénéficiaires de
l'aide alimentaire sur les 10
dernières années en France.
Une multiplication par 3 des
bénéficiaires avec une augmentation
drastique ces deux dernières années.
Evidemment, vous le savez, les trois
quarts de ces bénéficiaires sont des
femmes.
Toujours les premières victimes de
l'indifférence générale.
Il y en a qui ricanent à côté.
La Banque alimentaire du Bas-Rhin me
rappelait cela hier encore.
Dans les supermarchés, les prix
explosent.
En particulier ceux des aliments
premiers prix, autour de 30%.
Le cercle vicieux de l'inflation bat
son plein.
Le budget d'alimentation des ménages
est en recul.
Pourtant, pour parler votre langage,
la pauvreté coûte beaucoup plus cher
que les investissements nécessaires
à son éradication.
Nous proposons donc une chose,
faisons des économies en agissant.
On évalue entre 8 et 10 millions le
nombre de personnes qui ne mangent
pas assez ou pas à leur faim.
Vous nous parlez de chèques et de
paniers, le champ lexical est là,
mais l'action, on l'attend.
On propose une réponse d'urgence.
Nous avons cherché à rendre une aide
acceptable.
On propose d'éviter 4000 cancers par
an en supprimant les nitrites et de
prendre soin des enfants et du
climat en renforçant le repas
végétarien dans les cantines.
Pourquoi le gouvernement fait-il le
choix de mettre en danger sanitaire
et alimentaire la population
française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible
dans votre indignation si vous aviez
voté les mesures que nous avons
adoptées pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages les plus modestes.
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible,
vous et toute la NUPES, si vous
aviez voté la revalorisation des
APL, la revalorisation des minima
sociaux, la revalorisation des
bourses étudiantes dont vient de
parler Sylvie Retailleau, le repas à
1 euro pour les boursiers...
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible
dans notre -- votre indignation si
vous aviez voté l'indemnité
carburant pour les travailleurs!
Pour ceux qui travaillent!
Pour ceux qui sont les plus
modestes!
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible
dans votre indignation sur
l'inflation si vous aviez voté le
bouclier qui protège tous les
ménages français contre l'explosion
des prix du gaz.
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible si,
au lieu de faire preuve d'idéologie
sur les propositions que nous avons
faites pour protéger nos
compatriotes, vous aviez soutenu les
mesures du gouvernement et de la
Première ministre pour le pouvoir
d'achat des plus modestes.
Vous seriez plus crédible dans votre
indignation pour les plus modestes
si vous et La France Insoumise vous
n'aviez pas proposé de supprimer la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires, des ouvriers, des
employés, des travailleurs les plus
modestes, de ceux qui sont au niveau
du SMIC...
Vous allez leur voler 150 euros par
mois en supprimant la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires!
Vous seriez un peu plus crédible,
vous et La France Insoumise, dans
votre indignation, pour les plus
modestes, pour les commerçants, pour
les artisans, si vous n'aviez pas
voté et proposé l'augmentation des
cotisations chez les employeurs qui
vont retirer 700 euros par mois!
Voilà La France Insoumise!
Des indignations de pacotille!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Bilde
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Bruno Bilde: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Le coût des énergies et des
carburants est un niveau rarement
atteint.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont les produits
courants qui ont vu leurs prix
augmenter de manière insupportable.
Le lait, + 10%.
Le beurre, + 1%.
Les vols à l'étalage explosent.
Nous n'avons jamais eu à traiter
autant de demandes de secours.
Jusqu'aux demandes de prise en
charge par les municipalités des
frais d'obsèques pour éviter aux
Français l'indigence.
Alors, les Français rognent sur
leurs loisirs, sur les produits de
première nécessité, mais surtout sur
leur santé.
Ils ne peuvent plus payer leur
mutuelle, pendant que les
clandestins continuent de bénéficier
de l'aide médicale d'Etat sans avoir
cotisé un centime.
En 10 ans, le nombre de
bénéficiaires des banques
alimentaires a été multiplié par
trois, dans l'immense partie sur les
deux dernières années, +22% de
fréquentation au Restos du coeur, du
jamais vu.
Les paniers anti-inflation
encouragés par le gouvernement sont
des outils marketing en faveur de la
seule grande distribution pour
prouver leur inefficacité.
Dans le même temps, vous refusez la
taxation des superprofits qui
permettrait d'aller chercher
ailleurs que dans les poches des
Français.
Vous refusez notre proposition de
TVA 0% sur les produits de première
nécessité.
On ne rechigne pas à faire des
cadeaux aux plus riches quand vous
réservez votre brutalité à d'autres.
Quand allez-vous entendre la
souffrance des Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Je vois que le Rassemblement
National a la même indignation de
façade que celle de la NUPES.
Ca ne me surprend pas.
Là aussi, monsieur Bruno Bilde, vous
seriez un peu plus crédibles dans
votre indignation de façade si vous
aviez voter le soutien aux
travailleurs, si vous aviez voté
l'indemnité carburant pour ceux qui
ont travaillé, si vous aviez soutenu
le bouclier énergétique sur les
factures de gaz et sur les factures
d'électricité qui ont protégé nos
compatriotes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît...
- Bruno Le Maire: La récupération,
la récupération des marges des
grandes entreprises énergétiques, ça
s'appelle la contribution sur la
rente.
Elle rapporte plusieurs millions
d'euros.
Elle permet de financer notre
bouclier sur le gaz.
bouclier sur l'électricité.
Madame Le Pen, vous n'avez pas
soutenu la contribution sur la rente
et vous ne proposez aucune solution
pour protéger nos compatriotes
contre la flambée des prix.
Quant aux prix de l'alimentaire,
j'ai demandé aux distributeurs de
mettre en place un trimestre
anti-inflation qui est appliqué
actuellement et dont nous
vérifierons la mise en oeuvre.
J'ai envoyé aujourd'hui la lettre
qui demande aux distributeurs et aux
industriels de rouvrir sans délai
les négociations commerciales pour
que les prix qui commencent à
baisser se répercutent à la
consommation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Marie-Agnès
Poussier-Winsback.
- Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre Hervé Berville.
Mes chers collègues, je viens d'un
territoire qui a subi l'arrêt de la
grande pêche dans les années 80,
plongeant le territoire dans une
crise profonde.
La ville a mis des décennies à se
remettre de cette décision
canadienne de remettre en place des
quotas.
La pêche en Normandie comme en
Bretagne, c'est une boussole.
Ca fixe le cap.
J'ai entendu les pêcheurs de mon
territoire, j'ai lu les déclarations
de notre président des pêches
maritimes et des élevages marins,
qui exprimait toute la colère d'une
profession.
"Une accumulation de normes, qui
remettent en cause le fondement même
de notre métier en nous
culpabilisant".
C'est terrible d'entendre ça.
Ces professionnels ont choisi ce
métier difficile pour de nombreuses
raisons, mais notamment pour nous
nourrir.
Aujourd'hui, ils ont besoin que nous
puissions leur redonner espoir.
Ils ont besoin que nous leur
accordions notre confiance.
Monsieur le ministre, comment
encourager des jeunes à choisir ce
métier ou à reprendre des activités,
quand des réglementations
européennes les mettre en danger?
Monsieur le ministre, je sais que
vous vous battez au quotidien aux
côtés des pêcheurs.
Pouvez-vous faire un point auprès de
la représenta nationale sur les
actions que vous portez pour les
défendre une profession?
entiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Hervé Berville.
- Hervé Berville: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, d'abord, je
voulais vous remercier de votre
engagement auprès des pêcheurs de
votre territoire pour continuer à
avoir cette filière qui fait la
fierté de nos espaces littoraux.
Oui, nous devons être fiers du
travail des pêcheurs qui, depuis des
dizaines d'années, ont démontré que
l'on pouvait allier et concilier
écologie du milieu marin et
développement de la filière.
C'est un enjeu de souveraineté
alimentaire.
Nous dépendons à plus de 80% pour
les exportations de nos poissons.
Je me suis rendu avec une délégation
à la Commission européenne dimanche
pour avoir la confirmation que la
proposition de la Commission
européenne n'était pas acceptable.
Vous le savez, je pense à la
coquille, à la langoustine, aux
producteurs d'huîtres.
Ils démontrent que nous devons
continuer à avoir une activité de
pêche partout sur le territoire.
Je me suis rendu en Vendée auprès
des pêcheurs pour les écouter, pour
continuer à travailler, et aussi
dans les Côtes-d'Armor.
Nous allons continuer à les
soutenir.
Plusieurs millions d'euros seront
débloqués pour réduire la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles.
Nous allons continuer, et je sais
que vous avez un lycée maritime sur
votre territoire, en investissant
fortement dans la formation, dans
les lycées.
Nous avons besoin d'avoir une pêche
en France.
C'est aussi un enjeu d'être fidèle à
notre héritage en la matière.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Danièle Obono.
- Danièle Obono: Rien n'y fera, ni
les 49.3 à répétition, ni les
arrestations arbitraires pour
étouffer la contestation, sous le
regard réprobateur de toutes les
institutions nationales et
internationales de défense des
droits humains et de l'Etat de
droit, ni les tentatives de
diversion dans différents
magazines, ni les consultations
commanditées par Emmanuel Macron
pour "bâtir un programme de
gouvernement et un programme
législatif" neuf mois après être
arrivé au pouvoir.
Aucun des groupes parlementaires
de la NUPES ne participera à cette
mascarade.
Le rejet de votre réforme des
retraites est massif.
68% des Françaises et des Français
y sont toujours fermement opposés.
L'agitation populaire persiste et
signe partout dans le pays.
Les étudiantes et étudiants de
différentes universités en
Ile-de-France mais aussi à Lille,
Pau, Poitiers, Toulouse, Grenoble,
Caen et Nantes sont entrés en
lutte.
Les blocages continuent.
Hier, c'était le périphérique de
Nantes.
Ce matin, Grenoble.
Malgré les réquisitions, des
grèves sont reconduites dans
plusieurs secteurs.
Des raffineries sont à l'arrêt.
Un préavis de grève illimitée des
éboueurs parisiens a été annoncé à
partir du 13 avril.
Gloire aux grévistes!
Nous ne lâcherons rien!
Il n'y aura pas de trêve, pas de
suspension, pas de médiation, a
affirmé la toute nouvelle
secrétaire général de la CGT.
Ce jeudi, l'appel de
l'intersyndicale sera entendu par
les Français.
Vous voulez tourner la page,
sortir le pays du chaos social et
démocratique dans lequel
l'obstination d'un président
bunkerisé...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, vous vous posez comme la
porte-parole des quatre groupes de
gauche qui composent l'hémicycle
pour dire que vous ne participerez
à rien.
Il n'y a rien de nouveau dans
votre intervention: vous ne
proposez rien.
Vous dissimulez la réalité de
votre projet.
Dites-le, madame Obono, vous
voulez prendre de l'argent à ceux
qui gagnent un peu plus de 1500
euros par mois.
Dites que vous voulez prendre de
l'argent à tous ceux qui font
vivre nos quartiers et à nos
artisans.
Dites que vous voulez rendre
l'emploi plus cher.
Dites que vous voulez du chômage
et de la pauvreté.
Votre projet, c'est la ruine et
l'appauvrissement des Français.
La seule chose que vous proposez,
la seule chose que vous défendez,
c'est une terrible inversion des
valeurs.
Vous faites des policiers les
responsables, alors que ce sont
les casseurs, les responsables.
Vous souhaitez les blocages et le
désordre, la chienlit, vous
souhaitez délégitimer les
institutions de la République.
La seule chose que vous voulez,
c'est le désordre et l'anarchie.
Nous sommes le camp de la
responsabilité et de la raison, et
nous ne vous laisserons pas faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Emilie Bonnivard.
- Emilie Bonnivard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Il y a urgence.
Tel est le cri que vous adressent
tous les professionnels des EHPAD
et des services de soins à
domicile qui accompagnent les
personnes âgées.
Les voyants sont au rouge: pénurie
quasi généralisée de personnels
soignants, des établissements en
déficit en raison de l'inflation,
épuisement des professionnels qui
restent en poste.
Les soignants sont contraints, par
manque de temps, d'effectuer leur
métier pourtant profondément
humain à la chaîne.
Cinq minutes pour un lavage de
pieds, pas de temps pour plus
d'une douche par semaine, cinq
minutes pour la pose de bas de
contention et pas une seconde de
plus pour un temps d'échange.
Car il faut passer au suivant.
Ce que nous faisons vivre, aussi
bien aux aînés qu'aux
professionnels qui les
accompagnent, par manque de
moyens, est inhumain.
C'est une forme de maltraitance
institutionnelle subie.
A quoi servons-nous ici, dans
notre mandat, si nous ne sommes
pas capables de mettre au coeur de
nos priorités le soin des plus
fragiles, de nos aînés, de leur
permettre de vivre dans la
douceur, la dignité et avec
humanité?
Nous examinons en ce moment une
proposition de loi du groupe
majoritaire dénommée "Pour une
société du bien vieillir".
Mais on va se dire la vérité, on
est complètement à côté de la
plaque.
On est en décalage total avec les
besoins criants du terrain.
Aucun des problèmes majeurs qui
conduisent à cette situation
intenable n'est traité.
Rien sur les moyens budgétaires,
rien sur l'attractivité réelle des
métiers du grand âge, rien sur la
formation.
Ma question est simple: à quand de
vrais moyens et une vraie réforme
en faveur du grand âge?
Il y a urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Madame la députée
Emilie Bonnivard, comme c'est une
question qui porte sur le grand
âge, c'est mon collègue
Jean-Christophe Combe qui aurait
dû vous répondre, mais il est
justement occupé sur ce sujet du
grand âge.
Nous sommes dans une situation
critique dans beaucoup de domaines
du médico-social, avec un profond
problème d'attractivité des
métiers, que nous avons pris à
bras-le-corps avec la question du
Ségur, qui a permis d'augmenter
les salaires, mais qui ne répond
pas suffisamment à la souffrance
des soignants, qui sont trop
souvent en sous-effectif.
On sait que cela peut amener à des
difficultés de recrutement.
Le seul point de désaccord que
j'aurai avec vous, c'est quand
vous dites qu'il n'y a pas
d'ambition budgétaire.
Entre 2021 et 2026, ce sont plus
de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires annuels consacrés
à l'accompagnement du bien
vieillir, notamment dans le virage
domiciliaire mais aussi dans les
établissements médico-sociaux.
Dans le mandat précédent, il y a
eu la création de la cinquième
branche.
Avec cette création, il existe un
mécanisme qui fait qu'à partir de
l'année prochaine, il y aura une
part de la CSG qui va venir
abonder les fonds pour pouvoir
financer davantage de dépenses de
prise en charge des personnes
âgées en établissement ou à
domicile.
L'ambition budgétaire est là.
C'est assez rare que d'avoir
déterminé un budget avant de
déterminer dans la loi comment on
va le dépenser.
Nous avons annoncé 50.000
recrutements supplémentaires dans
les cinq années sur le secteur
médico-social, notamment pour les
personnes âgées.
C'est un plan de recrutement
massif, mais ça ne suffit pas.
C'est pourquoi il fallait une
proposition parlementaire de loi
de la majorité.
Elle va permettre d'améliorer tout
ce qui est gouvernance...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Pascale
Boyer.
- Pascale Boyer: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la Cohésion des territoires.
Jeudi 30 mars, le président de la
République est venu annoncer le
plan eau dans une commune
symbolique des Hautes-Alpes car au
bout des années 60, cet ancien
village a été recouvert par les
eaux pour la création d'un lac.
Cette retenue d'eau a permis
l'écrêtement des crues de la
Durance, la production
d'hydroélectricité avec le
barrage, l'irrigation agricole en
aval de la vallée et une activité
touristique attirant des centaines
de milliers de touristes chaque
été dans le département des
Hautes-Alpes.
Ce plan attendu fait partie des
priorités de la planification
écologique en apportant des
réponses aux enjeux
environnementaux et économiques.
L'année 2022 a été marquée par une
sécheresse qui a duré plusieurs
mois et qui a touché la quasi
intégralité de notre territoire.
93 départements ont été soumis à
des restrictions d'eau, et plus de
1000 communes ont connu des
ruptures d'approvisionnement en
eau potable.
Le début de cette année a été
marqué par une sécheresse
hivernale qui a duré 32 jours.
Comment préparer rapidement l'été
2023 et éviter les coupures en eau
potable, sécuriser
l'approvisionnement en eau potable
de nos concitoyens et diminuer les
fuites dans les réseaux?
Comment informer nos concitoyens
des écogestes à adopter pour
économiser 10% d'eau dans tous les
secteurs d'ici 2030?
Pour la production d'énergie, pour
l'agriculture, pour les
collectivités territoriales, pour
les territoires d'outre-mer et
pour les particuliers?
A travers ce plan, c'est une
véritable politique de l'eau qui
se met en place pour organiser
notre sobriété, pour préserver la
qualité de l'eau.
Pouvez-vous nous dire comment les
mesures annoncées par le président
de la République la semaine
dernière vont nous permettre de
faire face aux sécheresses à venir
et d'améliorer considérablement la
gestion de l'eau?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée Pascale Boyer, demain,
nous publierons la mission
d'inspection qui établit le retour
d'expérience de la sécheresse que
nous avons connue l'été dernier.
C'est une sécheresse hors normes
qui a touché 93 départements par
des restrictions.
Depuis le mois de septembre, 500
chantiers ont été lancés pour
sécuriser une partie de l'été qui
arrive.
Depuis septembre dernier, dès le
23 février, avec Bérangère
Couillard, nous avons réuni le
Comité d'anticipation sécheresse,
et les préfets, et au-delà de ces
mesures de réparation qui se
poursuivent a été présenté il y a
quelques jours le plan eau dont
les fondations ont été posées sous
l'égide de la Première ministre à
la fin du mois de septembre, à
Marseille.
Ces 53 mesures, c'est compliqué de
les détailler devant vous, mais je
suis sûr que j'aurai l'occasion
d'entrer dans le détail.
Je me contenterai de
quelques-unes.
D'abord, économiser l'eau, en
faisant en sorte d'avoir des
trajectoires de baisse de nos
prélèvements, territoire par
territoire, bassin par bassin,
avec des plans d'adaptation au
changement climatique à hauteur de
10% avant la fin de cette année.
Deuxièmement, faire en sorte
d'optimiser la ressource, lutter
contre les fuites.
Il y a 20% de fuites en moyenne
sur nos réseaux d'eau potable dans
notre pays.
Réutiliser les eaux usées: c'est
un chantier à faire.
Préparer la gouvernance, donner
des moyens et faire en sorte de
sensibiliser nos concitoyens à
travers une application simple et
géolocalisée, voilà les
principales mesures.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Soumya Bourouaha.
- Soumya Bourouaha: Merci.
Malgré vos incantations à passer à
autre chose, les Français ne
tournent pas la page.
Ils sont, dans leur immense
majorité, chaque jour, encore
mobilisés pour vous dire leur
refus d'un recul à 64 ans de l'âge
de départ à la retraite.
Notre groupe tient à dire toute
son admiration aux travailleuses
et travailleurs qui poursuivent
leur action de grève, partout sur
le territoire, malgré ce qui leur
en coûte au quotidien: éboueurs,
raffineurs, dockers, agents de la
RATP, de la SNCF, enseignants,
soignants, à tous, nous leur
adressons notre soutien sans
faille.
Notre groupe tient aussi à saluer
la jeunesse qui, aux côtés des
travailleurs et des retraités,
exprime une autre vision de la
société.
Notre groupe tient aussi à assurer
à nos concitoyens qu'ici aussi
nous ne lâchons rien.
C'est pourquoi, ce matin, les
parlementaires communistes
et ultramarins et les députés du
groupe LIOT se sont présentés
devant l'Elysée afin
d'interpeller, une fois encore, le
premier responsable de cette
situation de crise sociale et
démocratique, Emmanuel Macron.
Nous lui avons remis un courrier
dans lequel nous lui rappelons que
la revendication des Français et
de leurs représentants à un droit
juste et digne à la retraite est
pleinement légitime.
En revanche, ce qui est
illégitime, c'est cette réforme
contre le peuple qui n'a même pas
fait l'objet d'un examen
parlementaire abouti, ni même d'un
vote.
Ce qui est illégitime, c'est ce
gouvernement qui méprise
l'expression si forte, si
déterminé de nos concitoyens et
d'un front syndical historique par
son unité.
Le groupe GDR attend désormais une
seule réponse, celle du président
de la République auquel nous
disons encore: "Vous avez les
moyens et la responsabilité de la
sortie de crise, renoncez à votre
funeste réforme ou rendez la
parole au peuple en la soumettant
à un référendum."
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée Soumya Bourouaha, vous
dites que vous n'attendez qu'une
seule réponse, celle du président
de la République.
Je ne répondrai donc pas à sa
place.
Vous dites que vous ne lâcherez
rien et qu'on ne peut pas tourner
la page de cette réforme.
Je vous confirme que nous voulons
pas tourner la page.
Demain, nous recevrons
l'intersyndicale.
Nous évoquerons tous les sujets
qu'ils souhaitent évoquer.
Il n'est pas question de
considérer que cette réforme, une
fois votée, serait oubliée,
effacée.
Elle fait partie de notre
histoire, des acquis.
Nous aurons à la mettre en oeuvre.
Ne pas tourner la page, sous
réserve de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel, c'est veiller à
ce que l'ensemble des mesures
puissent être mises en place.
Nous ne tournons pas la page.
Nous souhaitons pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme car elle est
utile pour l'ensemble des
Français.
Nous voulons aussi continuer à
travailler pour ouvrir un certain
nombre de champs autour de la
gestion des carrières, pour
renforcer les dispositions que
nous avons déjà intégrées sur la
question de l'usure ou de l'emploi
des seniors.
Nous espérons que, demain, cette
reprise du dialogue permettra
d'envisager des possibilités de
convergence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Gisèle Lelouis.
- Gisèle Lelouis: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Hier, la France s'est réveillée
sous le choc de voir qu'à
Marseille, les fusillades
empiraient sur fond de trafic de
drogue.
3 morts, 12 blessés durant la
triple fusillade de ce week-end,
soit 14 tués par arme à feu et 43
blessés en trois mois.
Je veux saluer tout d'abord avec
le groupe Rassemblement National
le courage et le travail
formidable des services de secours
et de sécurité, submergés en
France et notamment à Marseille.
Mais comment ne peut-on pas être
triste et en colère lorsque
certains prétendent lutter contre
le trafic de drogue international
tout en installant des salles de
shoot?
Le renforcement de notre action
diplomatique de la douane, de la
justice et de la prévention
médicale sont urgents chez nous.
Certains consomment de la drogue
comme si c'était des bonbons.
Or, consommer donne une
responsabilité.
Comment se fait-il que seuls 30%
des consommateurs verbalisés
payent leurs amendes?
Comment responsabilisez-vous les
parents pour qu'ils empêchent
leurs gamins d'aller chouffer pour
1000 euros par jour?
Les gens ont peur de se prendre
une balle.
Moi-même j'ai connu cette peur.
Alors, vous envoyez la police puis
ils vont repartir et rien ne
changera.
Vous me répondez que des unités de
CRS ont été déployées en mars.
J'ai discuté avec certains d'entre
eux.
Ils repartent sur ordre, frustrés,
et le trafic reprend.
Depuis janvier, 500
interpellations ont eu lieu en
lien avec le trafic.
Combien ont été relâchés?
Que fait la justice?
Voilà deux ans et demi que vous
êtes ministre avec monsieur
Dupond-Moretti, et qu'avez-vous
fait?
Vous espériez beaucoup, ça devait
bien se passer, mais voilà, la
poussière mise sous le tapis
remonte à la figure.
C'est votre bilan, celui
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Quel plan de bataille pour sauver
Marseille sur le trafic de drogue?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Madame la
députée Gisèle Lelouis, il y a une
constance que je vous reconnais,
que je reconnais à votre parti:
vous ne loupez jamais un
rendez-vous cynique avec le
malheur.
Et, pendant ce temps-là, le
ministre de l'Intérieur et
moi-même, nous agissons, et nous
avons mis en place un plan
Marshall à Marseille.
Voilà comment il se décline.
En 2022, 20 magistrats nouveaux
sont arrivés.
10 nouveaux greffiers.
En 2023, 6 magistrats
supplémentaires.
En deux ans, 60 contractuels.
En matière de forces de sécurité
intérieure, c'est 300 policiers
qui sont arrivés.
Savez-vous comment on les a
embauchés?
Grâce au budget 2021 que vous
n'avez pas voté, grâce au budget
2022 que vous n'avez pas voté,
grâce au budget 2023 que vous
n'avez pas voté.
Alors, je voudrais enfin vous dire
que vous n'êtes pas commentateurs,
vous êtes acteurs de la vie
politique.
Dans les niches RN, que
proposez-vous pour la justice?
Zéro!
En réalité, madame la députée,
vous nous opposez le silence et la
critique.
Votre programme, je vais vous dire
ce que c'est: un cimetière de
certitudes, et vous êtes orphelins
du réalisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Esquenet-Goxes.
- Laurent Esquenet-Goxes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre délégué chargé des
Transports.
Le secteur aéronautique est l'une
des plus grandes fiertés
industrielles de notre pays.
Nous sommes une des cinq nations
capables de construire un avion de
A à Z.
Au total, c'est plus de 100
milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires générés par ce secteur.
Cependant, si nous devons faire
prospérer cette belle industrie,
nous devons aussi prendre soin de
notre planète.
Les connaissances et les
consciences évoluent, et nos
concitoyens ont beaucoup
d'attentes sur la transition de ce
secteur.
Les Français continuent à regarder
le ciel avec émerveillement.
Mais pour continuer à faire rêver,
l'avion doit se décarboner.
Les acteurs du secteur ont déjà
pris la mesure de ce défi, en
témoignent les engagements de
l'accord de Toulouse, signé en
2022, pour un secteur neutre en
carbone à l'horizon 2050.
Outre l'avion à hydrogène
développé en Haute-Garonne, le
développement des biocarburants
quasiment neutres en CO2 est une
condition indispensable à l'avenir
du secteur.
Le projet de règlement européen en
cours de discussion porte une
ambition forte d'intégration
progressive de ces carburants.
A l'heure où certains d'entre nous
privilégient systématiquement
l'interdiction à la recherche de
solutions, notre rôle est
d'accompagner avec vigueur cette
transition en défendant ce projet
ambitieux à l'échelle européenne
et peser de toutes nos forces afin
de rehausser ses objectifs.
Pouvez-vous nous confirmer
l'attachement du gouvernement au
développement de ces biocarburants
français?
Plus généralement, quel sera votre
méthode pour porter notre voix au
niveau européen et pour s'assurer
du soutien de cette industrie
capitale pour notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Monsieur le
député Esquenet-Goxes, vous avez
raison, nous avons une industrie
d'excellence qu'est
l'aéronautique, une industrie
d'innovation, d'exportation,
créatrice d'emplois.
Il n'y a aucun avenir pour
l'aviation sans décarbonation,
vous avez raison.
Nous portons cette stratégie avec
beaucoup de détermination au
niveau français, européen et même
international.
Il y a un an, sous présidence
française de l'Union Européenne,
nous avons porté un objectif de
décarbonation totale de ce secteur
d'ici à 2050.
J'ai porté cet objectif à Montréal
au niveau international.
Il engage 180 pays dans le monde.
Donc nous sommes engagés sur le
plan écologique, industriels et
économique dans cet immense
transformation, qui est un nouveau
chapitre de l'aviation après les
révolutions que nous avons connues
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle.
Nous réussirons cet objectif grâce
à notre savoir-faire unique au
monde.
Nous sommes le seul pays à savoir
produire un avion de A à Z.
La moitié de cette stratégie de
décarbonation, c'est l'innovation
dans les carburants durables.
La France a été pionnière en la
matière.
Votre Assemblée a voté le fait que
nous
ayons une incorporation
obligatoire de ces carburants dans
nos avions.
Nous avons un règlement européen
pour répondre qui sera adopté dans
les prochaines semaines.
Ce sera le premier règlement au
monde à fixer un objectif en 2030
d'incorporation massives de ces
carburants dans tous nos avions.
Nous avons réuni l'ensemble des
industriels, des énergéticiens
pour créer une filière française
de ces carburants durables.
Nous aurons l'occasion de
présenter une feuille de route
pour produire ces carburants
durables en France et en Europe.
Nous pouvons développer cette
filière.
Il faudra investir, comme nous le
faisons dans le cadre du plan
France 2030.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à David Guiraud.
- David Guiraud: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, nous avons découvert
que vous nous accusez d'être
complices d'un terrorisme
intellectuel.
Nous avons pensé qu'il s'agissait
d'un poisson d'avril, avec certes
un fonds de vérité, tout travail
intellectuel semblant vous
terroriser.
Mais pendant que vous étiez occupé
à recycler les théories de
l'extrême droite pour servir vos
ambitions personnelles, un compte
Twitter a révélé publiquement
l'existence de boucles Telegram
néonazies invitant à commettre des
attentats contre nos compatriotes
musulmans, et je vous parle là
d'un terrorisme bien concret.
Il a fallu que ces tweets sortent
pour vous forcer à réagir de la
plus faible des manières, puisque
vous avez demandé à Telegram de
simplement fermer ces canaux de
discussion.
Il y avait pourtant dans ces
groupes des membres actifs qui
étaient fonctionnaires ou
militaires.
L'Etat ne peut avoir qu'une seule
réponse envers eux: "Dehors!"
Mais hier, lors d'un débat
parlementaire sur le terrorisme
d'extrême droite proposé par la
NUPES, dans lequel vous n'êtes
même pas intervenu, dans lequel la
majorité parlementaire n'a pas
parlé une seconde, dans lequel
vous avez catapulté le ministre
des Outre-mer, les moignons de
votre extrême indigence sur le
sujet, l'Etat a répondu qu'il
n'avait pas à condamner des gens
qui exprimaient simplement une
opinion.
Pensez-vous vraiment qu'être
militaire et arborer des signes
nazis, ce n'est que témoigner une
opinion?
Que vous fassiez de la politique
de la pire des manières, c'est une
chose, mais vous n'avez pas le
droit de vous affranchir de vos
responsabilités.
Vous n'avez pas le droit de vider
les mots de leur sens pour
disqualifier vos adversaires,
de critiquer des associations
écologistes quand le terrorisme
d'extrême droite se structure sous
vos yeux.
Vous n'avez pas le droit
d'instrumentaliser la laïcité à
des fins politiques.
Qu'est-il advenu des millions
d'euros dépensés par le ministère?
Une mosquée a été saccagée, un
fidèle a été agressé.
Nous sommes dans une période à
risques pour nos compatriotes
musulmans.
Vous vous égarez.
Avant de faire campagne, vous
devez faire votre travail.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député David Guiraud, d'abord, je
vous demanderai d'avoir plus de
respect pour les membres du
gouvernement, et singulièrement
pour monsieur Carenco.
Il mérite d'avoir un minimum de
respect.
Malheureusement, ce mot n'est pas
dans votre bouche ni dans votre
comportement.
Deuxièmement, le priapisme avec
lequel vous évoquez mon action
vous fait malheureusement louper
la vérité.
Ce groupe Telegram était suivi par
les services de renseignement, ce
qui nous a permis de pouvoir
identifier les personnes, les 2300
abonnés de ce groupe Telegram, qui
indépendamment d'être fermé est
aujourd'hui judiciarisé pour être
identifié.
A notre connaissance, il n'y a pas
eu de membres de la police
nationale dans ce groupe Telegram.
Le parquet se réunit actuellement
avec la police judiciaire afin de
pouvoir confondre et faire
condamner ces personnes.
Plutôt que de crier et de
s'exciter, il suffit parfois de
travailler, mais il est vrai que
les services de renseignement ont
parfois besoin de confidentialité
et de secrets qu'ils ne partagent
pas avec l'actualité politique
tous les jours.
Je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir de
votre part, d'abord dans le lien
avec les extrêmes.
Oui, l'ultragauche et
l'ultradroite sont les deux
facettes d'un extrémisme qui
touche la société française.
Je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir.
C'est ce gouvernement qui a
dissout Génération Identitaire et
de nombreuses milices d'extrême
droite.
Quant au lien entre islamisme et
politique, venant de vous, ça ne
manque pas de sel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Patrick Hetzel.
- Patrick Hetzel: Madame la
ministre, il y a quelques mois, la
présidence de l'université Montaigne
de Bordeaux a interdit de parole une
philosophe en considérant qu'il y
avait un risque de trouble à l'ordre
public.
La semaine dernière, la même
présidence d'université a laisser
s'exprimer en son sein monsieur
Jean-Marc Rouillant.
Il a été condamné pour apologie du
terrorisme et a été emprisonné pour
deux assassinats à caractère
terroriste.
Il a déclaré au sujet des frères
Kouachi: "J'en ai marre des poncifs
antiterroristes.
Je les ai trouvés très courageux."
Tout ceci est choquant.
Je n'ose imaginer, madame la
ministre, que vous combattiez la
philosophie, mais que vous protégez
le terrorisme.
Vous assurez la tutelle des
universités et votre mission est de
garantir le contrôle de la légalité
des universités françaises.
On ne vous a pas entendue sur ce
sujet.
Pourquoi ce silence assourdissant?
Par ailleurs, que comptez-vous faire
pour combattre une telle inversion
des valeurs parfaitement
inacceptable au sein de notre
université française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sylvie Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Patrick Hetzel,
comme vous le savez, et vous l'avez
dit, il y a l'autonomie des
universités, ce qui ne permet pas
tout.
On travaille.
On travaille pour garder le calme,
éviter les blocus dans les
universités et permettre à ces
universités cette liberté
académique, en même temps que cette
expression, tout en gardant le droit
aux étudiants d'aller étudier, le
droit au personnel d'accéder aux
universités.
Monsieur le député, c'est un travail
quotidien, un travail quotidien que
nous menons pour nos étudiants.
Il semble que tout cela vous
intéresse.
Ce travail quotidien, les annonces
récentes sur nos étudiants, les
annonces récentes par rapport à tout
ce qui est liée aux universités...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la ministre.
Monsieur Patrick Hetzel, allez-y.
- Patrick Hetzel: Madame la
ministre, votre réponse est
incroyable.
Vous rendez compte que du coup, vous
êtes dans une situation où la même
université interdit une philosophe,
et ça, personne ne trouve à redire.
De l'autre côté, il y a l'apologie
du terrorisme qui ne semble pas vous
déranger.
Etre ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche devrait
assurer la légalité de tout cela.
La liberté académique doit être
défendue, elle doit aussi être
respectée.
Vous-même, vous avez pu constater
que trois jours après, une
dégradation massive de cette
université a été faite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Hervé de Lépinau.
- Hervé de Lépinau: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
Monsieur le ministre, le Salon de
l'agriculture a été le cadre
traditionnel pour se faire
photographier au cul des vaches,
mais pas que.
Cette édition 2023 fut aussi
l'occasion d'être les réceptacles
des doléances et des inquiétudes des
professionnels présents sur le
salon.
A cet égard, nous avons été alertés
par les difficultés rencontrées par
une majorité d'adhérents pour
rembourser les prêts garantis par
l'Etat dans le délai imparti.
L'activité viticole pendant le Covid
n'a pu se mettre en sommeil dans
l'attente de jours meilleurs.
Le cycle végétatif a nécessité les
mêmes travaux que d'habitude.
La commercialisation des stocks a
subi un coup d'arrêt du fait des
confinements successifs.
Les prêts garantis par l'Etat ont
été mis en place dans la foulée.
Aujourd'hui, il faut les rembourser.
Ceci est normal.
Une demande d'allongement du délai à
10 ans a été formulée à de nombreux
professionnels et rejetée par Bercy
au motif qu'une durée de
remboursement de cette importance ne
serait pas conforme au droit
européen d'aides directes aux
entreprises.
Puisque Bruxelles ne nous permet pas
d'être souverain pour les mécanismes
de soutien, l'engagement de l'Etat
devient une condition de survie pour
beaucoup d'exportations.
Il est demandé de substituer à ces
prêts des
allongements de la durée de
remboursement de manière acceptable
pour la trésorerie des entreprises.
Pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement
d'une mise en oeuvre rapide de ce
mécanisme de substitution, son coût
pour les finances publiques étant
bien moindre que les pertes fiscales
qu'occasionneraient des dépôts de
bilan d'entreprises?
Je vous remercie pour votre réponse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, je pense que vous
reconnaîtrez, monsieur le député,
que pendant toute la crise du Covid,
nous avons accompagné, soutenu, et
protégé les entreprises, que ce soit
dans la viticulture ou ailleurs.
Vous reconnaîtrez, même si votre
président vous fait le reproche
d'avoir trop dépensé pour protéger
les entreprises, que nous avons pris
en charge l'activité partielle, le
report de charges et ces fameux
prêts garantis par l'Etat.
Je confirme que nous n'avons laissé
tomber aucune entreprise pendant la
crise du Covid.
Nous ne laisserons tomber aucune
entreprise après la crise du Covid.
Nous n'avons pas sauvé les
entreprises en 2020 et 2021 pour les
laisser tomber en 2022 et 2023.
Toute entreprise qui rencontre des
difficultés financières que ce soit
dans l'agriculture ou ailleurs peut
demander auprès du médiateur du
crédit un allongement de son prêt
garanti par l'Etat de 6 ans à 10
ans.
Vous conviendrez avec moi que la
prise en charge par l'Etat n'est pas
la solution la plus appropriée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Hervé de Lépinau?
- Hervé de Lépinau: J'exprime ma
déception, vous n'avez pas répondu à
ma question.
10 ans de délais de remboursement de
prêts garantis par l'Etat, ce n'est
pas possible, mais un prêt bonifié
par l'Etat, c'est une garantie de
l'Etat.
Le coût de la mesure sera moindre
que les coûts des dépôts de bilan.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Lionel
Royer-Perreaut pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Lionel Royer-Perreaut: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre des Outre-mer,
Marseille souffre, Marseille pleure,
Marseille est en colère.
Dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi,
pas moins de trois règlements de
comptes ont eu lieu, entraînant la
mort de trois personnes dont un
adolescent de 16 ans, et
l'hospitalisation de huit autres.
Nous constatons depuis une
accélération de ces assassinats sur
fond de trafic de stupéfiants.
Une double logique de contrôle
territorial d'une part et de
vendetta d'autre part en seraient à
l'origine.
Cette situation est inquiétante, car
elle intervient alors que Marseille
connaît une augmentation sensible de
ses moyens de police et de justice.
300 policiers, 3 compagnies de CRS,
30 magistrats, 10 greffiers, tous en
poste au moment même où nous nous
parlons, et ce, grâce à la décision
du président de la République.
Le travail réalisé à titre
d'illustration a permis de
démanteler définitivement 39 points
de deal, de saisir beaucoup de
cannabis et de dresser 18.600
amendes forfaitaires délictuelles
pour usage de stupéfiants.
Pour autant, nous sommes de plus en
plus nombreux à ne pas accepter
cette résignation qui semble
s'abattre sur la ville qui est
plongée dans la terreur et la
douleur.
Nous devons occuper plus encore les
quartiers par le renforcement de la
présence de CRS.
Monsieur le ministre, ma question
est simple.
Quels sont les moyens précis que
vous comptez allouer à Marseille de
façon pérenne pour mieux lutter
contre cette situation dramatique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Je crois que le garde des Sceaux a
évoqué les moyens de la justice
mobilisés à Marseille en complément
de la police nationale.
Ceci n'a pas d'équivalent sur aucun
territoire de la République.
C'est du jamais vu.
Nous continuerons cette progression.
Je veux dire en effet que c'est
parce que nous mettons énormément de
moyens et parce que les résultats,
depuis le 1er janvier...
1,2 tonnes de cannabis saisies en
moins de trois mois et 48 kg de
cocaïne, ainsi que 340 armes
saisies: cela montre l'hyperactivité
des services, mais aussi la maire
de Marseille.
J'ai décidé, pour mettre fin aux
vendettas et aux guerres de
territoire, puisque la procureure de
la République s'est exprimée et a dit
que nous avons des craintes pour la
conquête de ces territoires par des
gens qui sont mis hors d'état de
nuire par les services de police...
J'ai renforcé pour le mois de
septembre prochain les services
d'enquête de la police judiciaire à
Marseille.
Un nouveau groupe d'appuis
spécialisés fait un travail très
important.
A Marseille, la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue est une lutte qui
est très ancienne et internationale.
La maîtrise du port de Marseille est
un sujet extrêmement important pour
nous tous.
Le lien qu'il y a entre les
trafiquants qui commandent les
assassinats ciblés et leur présence
à l'extérieur de notre territoire...
On pense à des pays du Maghreb et du
Moyen-Orient, c'est extrêmement
important.
L'été dernier, nous avons tenté
d'avoir une meilleure coopération
pour obtenir des extraditions.
Nous travaillons pour que les
condamnations tombent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la Santé.
Monsieur le ministre, depuis hier,
la loi permet le plafonnement des
salaires pour les intérimaires.
Pour autant, cette loi n'est pas
sans conséquences et accroît les
difficultés pour nos hôpitaux de
proximité déjà confrontée à une
pénurie de soignants.
Dans l'Aisne, mon département, dans
de nombreuses villes, mais aussi
partout en France, la tension
s'accélère dans les services.
En pédiatrie, dans de nombreux
services spécialisés aussi, la
tension monte.
Des interventions chirurgicales sont
déprogrammées, comme pendant le
Covid.
Des lits sont gelés, pour ne pas
dire fermés.
Vous tentez d'atténuer les effets
pervers de la loi Rist en donnant
une prime de solidarité
territoriale, mais là n'est pas
l'urgence.
Au final, si votre disposition est
nécessaire, elle doit être
accompagnée de solutions durables.
Quand allez-vous engager de
nouvelles concertations pour vous
attaquer aux vrais problèmes?
Quelles sont vos propositions
pérennes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Je vous remercie, monsieur le
député, de reconnaître la validité
et la mise en application d'une loi
votée dans cet hémicycle en 2016,
une seconde loi votée dans cet
hémicycle en 2021.
Il était temps de la mettre en
application.
De quoi parle-t-on?
Pas de cette loi dans son ensemble,
mais d'une dérive de cet intérêt
médical qui s'apparente à un
mercenariat qui fait que les
hôpitaux sont les plus touchés.
Il faut retrouver l'éthique si nous
voulons retrouver notre système de
santé optimal.
Il faut favoriser nos professionnels
de santé qui sont dans les hôpitaux,
qui tiennent encore la ligne et qui
sont plus fortement sollicités.
Pour cela, j'ai rencontré les
organisations syndicales.
Nous allons nous revoir la semaine
prochaine pour améliorer les
conditions de travail de ces
professionnels.
Vous dites que partout, il y a des
difficultés.
Aujourd'hui, je peux dire que
partout, il y a des solutions qui
ont été trouvées.
Dans votre département, l'engagement
territorial de ce l'hôpital de
Saint-Quentin a fait que la
situation s'améliore.
Oui, il faut régler les situations
et assainir notre système de santé.
Cela en fait partie, mais
parallèlement, nous commençons à
construire et nous continuons à
construire de bonnes conditions de
travail pour les praticiens à
l'hôpital.
Mon objectif est de garder les bons
médecins et de faire revenir ceux
qui sont partis.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout?
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Encore une
fois, je crois que c'est la santé de
nos concitoyens avant tout.
Des propositions transpartisanes
sont sur la table.
Je vous ai proposé l'expérimentation
de l'école normale de la santé pour
répondre aux besoins de nos
territoires.
Ce serait bien d'autoriser cette
expérimentation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Caroline Fiat.
- Caroline Fiat: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé:
tout ça pour ça...
Une structure gouvernementale sur
une proposition de loi, du jamais vu
sous la Ve République, pour
aujourd'hui nous trouver une
nouvelle excuse, les modalités.
Pourtant, depuis la suspension, il
n'y a eu aucune modalité
particulière, quand celles et ceux
qui avaient attrapé le virus
retournaient travailler car ils
étaient considérés comme immunisés.
Vous avez sans cesse dit que la date
butoir serait celle de la Haute
Autorité de Santé.
Celle-ci a rendu un avis positif le
30 dernier.
Depuis, plus rien.
La loi du 30 juillet 2022 dit qu'au
regard de l'évolution de la
situation épidémiologique telle que
l'a constatée la Haute Autorité de
Santé, l'obligation vaccinale n'est
plus justifiée.
Celle-ci est suspendue par décret.
Il n'est pas question de
concertation quelconque.
Alors, monsieur le ministre, de
quelles modalités parlez-vous?
Vous savez aussi bien que moi que
dans tous les établissements, nous
avons cruellement besoin d'eux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée Caroline Fiat,
vous ne pouvez pas, en tant que
soignante, mélanger la situation
épidémiologique d'il y a plusieurs
mois avec celle d'aujourd'hui.
Je rappelle que la Haute Autorité de
Santé a reconnu que la vaccination a
sauvé des vies.
Je voudrais qu'on entende encore une
fois le remerciement des
représentants de la nation envers
ces professionnels de santé qui se
sont fait vacciner et qui ont tenu
la ligne, qui ont sauvé des vies.
Concernant l'avis de la Haute
Autorité de Santé, il s'agit d'un
avis sur les obligations vaccinales.
Elle touche le Covid, la diphtérie,
le tétanos, la poliomyélite,
l'hépatite B.
Cet avis est assorti de commentaires
extrêmement divers de la part des
professionnels et de beaucoup de
critiques.
Pour autant, la loi va suivre la
Haute Autorité de Santé.
L'obligation vaccinale est levée.
Maintenant, il faut travailler à la
réintégration des soignants.
Je souhaite qu'ils soient accueillis
par les services mais beaucoup de
professionnels de santé sont opposés
à leur retour.
Je ne veux pas créer de nouvelles
crises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Caroline Fiat.
- Caroline Fiat: Monsieur le
ministre, merci pour vos
remerciements.
Soignante pendant la crise, j'ai été
vaccinée dès janvier 2021.
Je sais pertinemment que des
soignants, parce qu'ils avaient
attrapé la Covid, dit immunisés,
sont déjà retournés dans les
services pour lesquels vous n'avez
rien prévu.
Pourquoi faudrait-il une modalité
aujourd'hui, monsieur le ministre de
la Santé?
C'est totalement incohérent.
Ces personnes n'ont pas eu de
salaire pendant plusieurs mois.
Vous les avez suspendus.
Maintenant, réintégrez-les.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Charles
Larsonneur.
- Jean-Charles Larsonneur: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher, ministre de la
Transition énergétique.
Notre pays fait face à un défi
immense à l'horizon 2040, garantir
une énergie en quantité suffisante
et un prix abordable.
Face à la raréfaction, c'est notre
modèle démocratique, économique et
social qui est en jeu.
C'est à notre génération de mener à
bien une passionnante aventure
industrielle et humaine sur le temps
long.
Les discours du président de la
République et les deux lois
successivement votées dans cet
hémicycle avec des majorités nettes
sur l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et du nucléaire ont
d'autre part posé des jalons
importants.
Je veux rendre hommage aux femmes et
aux hommes engagés dans cette grande
aventure industrielle.
Soudeurs, tuyauteurs, chaudronniers,
que nos entreprises se disputent
chèrement dans tous les bassins
d'emploi, de Brest à Saint-Nazaire,
comme ailleurs.
Dans les années à venir, nous devons
répondre simultanément à la montée
en puissance du nucléaire, de la
filière éolienne, à une croissance
vigoureuse de la construction
navale...
Nous risquons de manquer de cerveaux
et de bras.
Des filières font leur part grâce à
la formation interne.
Les chambres consulaires
accompagnent les apprentis.
Peut-être manquons-nous encore de
nouvelles écoles techniques.
Comment abordez-vous ce défi qui est
à venir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Larsonneur, notre
politique vise à faire de la France
le premier grand pays des énergies
fossiles.
Nous avons l'ambition de relancer la
filière nucléaire
et c'est l'une des plus grandes
aventures industrielles qu'ait connu
notre pays depuis les années 70.
C'est un projet humain et industriel
exceptionnel.
C'est un projet qui va nécessiter
énormément de compétences.
Nous allons devoir recruter plus de
10.000 talents dans tous les
niveaux, du bac professionnel
jusqu'aux post-doctorants.
Ce sont tous types de métiers, ainsi
que des chercheurs que nous devons
convaincre de venir dans ces
filières.
Vous avez raison de le souligner,
nous avons envoyé un signal positif
sur les rangs de cette Assemblée à
la filière nucléaire.
Nous agissons.
J'ai l'ambition de lancer un plan
Marshall des compétences dans la
filière nucléaire.
Nous y travaillons avec la réunion
de l'ensemble des industriels.
On me remettra dans les prochains
jours le bilan des évaluations des
besoins en compétences.
Dans les semaines qui vont suivre,
nous allons élaborer le plan de
formation qu'il faudra instaurer
derrière.
C'est un plan de formation pour les
jeunes.
C'est aussi un plan de formation de
reconversion.
Nous devons attirer des talents
aussi dans cette filière qui ont une
base industrielle, ou dans d'autres
métiers.
Je crois qu'il faut saluer cette
opportunité exceptionnelle que nous
offre aujourd'hui la transition
énergétique pour bâtir des filières
et nourrir des emplois.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Karine Lebon.
- Karine Lebon: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre des Outre-mer,
l'esprit de la loi de 2012 visait à
répondre à l'urgence sociale de la
vie chère dans les territoires
ultramarins.
Un bouclier a apporté une réponse
nécessaire sans laquelle les
Français d'outre-mer auraient pu
faire face à la flambée des prix.
Nous payons déjà nos produits 30% de
plus que dans l'Hexagone, alors que
la population y est plus pauvre.
Pour l'année en cours, 153 produits
sont concernés par le bouclier
qualité-prix à La Réunion.
Vous avez assuré aux parlementaires
du Sénat que ce bouclier devrait
concerner entre 250 et 300 produits
dans les territoires ultramarins.
Le compte n'y est pas.
"Le nouveau bouclier qualité-prix
étendu au secteur du bricolage"?
Pourtant, les citoyens qui viennent
me voir au quotidien dans ma
permanence parlementaire le font
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
remplir leur frigo, et 'ont -- non
pas parce qu'ils doivent planter un
clou.
Nous remettons régulièrement ce
sujet sur la table à coups
d'amendements, de propositions de
commission d'enquête, et que vous
soyez
las n'y changera rien.
Nous n'abandonnerons pas tant que le
dispositif n'aura pas évolué et que
des solutions concrètes n'auront pas
été trouvées.
Alors que le gouvernement répète son
attachement à la co-construction, ce
n'est pas le choix qui a été fait
concernant nos territoires.
Nous n'avons été conviés qu'à la
restitution des travaux d'une
assemblée précédente.
Allez-vous entendre nos
propositions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-François
Carenco.
- Jean-François Carenco: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Je me catapulte pour vous répondre.
La vie chère et le pouvoir d'achat,
pour vous comme pour nous, sont une
préoccupation constante.
Avec Gérald Darmanin, nous avions
annoncé le plan contre la vie chère.
Je me permets de vous rappeler les
principaux résultats.
La stabilisation des boucliers
qualité-prix, une diminution
sensible dans certains territoires.
C'est une réalité.
Le bouclier a été élargi à de
nouveaux produits qui correspondent
aux habitudes de consommation locale.
Le nombre des distributeurs a été
augmenté.
Cela est important dans tous les
territoires.
Ce panier élargi contient des
produits de bricolage, mais aussi
des services multimédias, des
forfaits téléphoniques.
Cela fait l'objet d'accords de
modération des prix dans presque
tous les territoires, sauf à La
Réunion.
Je peux répondre?
Merci.
Il est vrai que dans le cadre de La
Réunion, les prix n'ont pas été
intégrés officiellement dans
l'accord de modération des prix.
Néanmoins, ce bouclier est le plus
étoffé de tous les boucliers
d'outre-mer.
Je rappelle que nous avons fait
preuve d'efficacité.
L'inflation de La Réunion et de 3,9%
contre 6% en métropole.
Le prix du carburant est plus faible
que dans l'Hexagone.
En avril, le prix du gazole était de
1,4 euro par litre.
Le prix du sans plomb, de 1,74 euro.
Le prix de l'électricité a augmenté.
Maintenant, je réponds à votre
question.
Les préfets conduisent les
négociations...
Allô?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
Vous avez 4 secondes.
- Karine Lebon: 153 produits.
Ce n'est pas 250 ou 300 produits.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à Frédéric Falcon.
- Frédéric Falcon: Les personnels
suspendus soumis à l'obligation
vaccinale contre la Covid-19
vivent depuis septembre 2021 sous
un statut inique créé par
Elisabeth Borne.
Après avoir encensé ceux qui se
sont mobilisés pendant la période
Covid, vous avez mis au ban de la
société des milliers de soignants,
de militaires ou encore des
pompiers alors que nous manquons
d'effectifs dans ces professions.
Ces personnes que vous laissez
mourir à petit feu sont les
martyrs de ce macronisme
autoritaire qui broie les
Français.
Malgré vos affirmations
mensongères et votre volonté de
minimiser l'impact de cette mesure
infondée à seulement
quelques milliers, les
conséquences vont bien au-delà des
chiffres que vous avancez.
Combien de personnels ont pris
leur retraite anticipée?
Combien ont refusé le
renouvellement d'un contrat?
Combien ont démissionné?
Combien ont été licenciés?
Combien se sont reconvertis?
Combien se sont détournés de leur
vocation?
Les ARS refusent de me répondre.
Nombre d'établissements de santé
nous rapportent leurs difficultés
à recruter.
Dans ma circonscription, cette
obligation vaccinale prive un
village entier de son dernier
médecin.
Ce praticien a préféré partir
exercer en Espagne, pays qui n'a
jamais imposé d'obligation
vaccinale, comme de nombreux
autres pays européens.
Tous les pays qui avaient instauré
cette obligation y ont mis fin.
La France est le dernier pays à
s'enfermer dans son narratif,
malgré le déclin de la maladie.
Le Rassemblement National s'est
toujours opposé à cette obligation
vaccinale.
Il est le seul à avoir déposé une
proposition de loi visant à
réintégrer sans condition les
personnels suspendus et à les
indemniser, opposition bloquée par
le gouvernement et certains
groupes d'oppositions.
Suite à l'avis de la Haute
Autorité de Santé préconisant la
levée de l'obligation vaccinale,
quand allez-vous enfin réintégrer
mais également indemniser les
personnels suspendus?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à François Braun.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député Falcon, je constate
malheureusement que, quand il
s'agit de faire des raccourcis
d'histoire, les deux extrêmes se
rejoignent.
Au risque de me répéter, et puis
peut-être de donner une lecture un
peu plus détaillée de ce qu'a
écrit la HAS, nous avons toujours
suivi ses avis depuis le début de
la crise, et elle précise que la
vaccination et la vaccination des
soignants a sauvé
des vies.
Les martyrs, ce sont les personnes
qui sont décédées du Covid.
qui sont en Covid long, qui
n'arrivent plus à vivre
correctement.
Les martyrs, ce sont les soignants
qui étaient en première ligne et
qui ont maintenant des troubles
parce qu'ils sont épuisés du
travail qu'ils ont fait, pendant
que d'autres ne se faisaient pas
dans l'hôpital.
Lorsqu'on parle de martyrs, un
petit peu d'humilité.
J'y étais, d'autres soignants y
étaient, nous savons de quoi nous
parlons.
En ce qui concerne la
réintégration des soignants, je
l'ai dit, cette réintégration
n'est pas dans l'avis de la Haute
Autorité de Santé.
La loi sera appliquée.
Cette réintégration devra se faire
dans les meilleures conditions
pour ne pas créer une crise des
soignants.
La discussion sur la vaccination
n'est pas terminée.
Il y a d'autres vaccinations
fortement recommandées.
Le débat n'est pas fini.
S'il vous plaît, utilisez les bons
mots.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Frédéric Falcon: Je crois que
vous êtes incapable de toute
remise en question.
Emmanuel Macron et ce gouvernement
ont saccagé la vie de milliers de
Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Didier Martin.
- Didier Martin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
Vous étiez présente hier au palais
de l'Elysée avec Olivier Véran,
avec François Braun, pour la
restitution des travaux de la
Convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie.
Vous avez entendu les conclusions
que le président de la République
en a tiré.
Permettez-moi d'abord de saluer
cette démarche de démocratie
innovante, la démocratie
délibérative, qui prend place au
côté de la démocratie
représentative et qui prépare en
quelque sorte nos travaux.
C'est le sens de la déclaration du
président de la République qui
invite le gouvernement et une
délégation de parlementaires à
préparer une nouvelle loi.
Une loi de plus pour un droit de
plus pour ceux qui veulent mettre
fin dignement à leur vie, quand
ils sont dans des conditions que
la délibération permettra de
préciser, des conditions très
précises concernant la volonté, le
discernement, l'état de santé, le
pronostic et, bien sûr, les
souffrances réfractaires.
Mais le premier pilier de cette
restitution rejoint les travaux de
la mission d'évaluation de la loi
Claeys-Leonetti que nous avons
terminée la semaine dernière.
Ces travaux concernent les soins
palliatifs.
C'est le sens de ma question.
Le constat est assez clair:
l'offre de soins palliatifs est
inégale et insuffisante sur
l'ensemble du territoire national.
Il convient de faire ce diagnostic
lucidement et de voir ce qui a été
fait et ce qui reste à faire pour
la formation, pour l'appui des
équipes de soins palliatifs, alors
quel sens donnez-vous et
voulez-vous donner à ce plan
national décennal de lutte contre
la douleur et des soins
palliatifs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Monsieur
le député Didier Martin, le 13
septembre dernier, le président de
la République, a souhaité ouvrir
le débat sur la fin de vie, comme
il s'y était engagé pendant la
campagne électorale.
Le 9 décembre dernier, la Première
ministre ouvrait la convention
citoyenne où 184 citoyens tirés au
sort ont travaillé jusqu'au
dimanche 2 avril.
L'Assemblée nationale s'est
emparée de ce sujet avec
l'évaluation de la loi
Claeys-Leonetti, une évaluation
nécessaire, et je remercie Olivier
Falorni, Caroline Fiat et Didier
Martin qui ont travaillé à cette
évaluation nécessaire.
Le gouvernement s'est emparé aussi
de travaux avec une commission
transpartisane de parlementaires,
de soignants et d'usagers avec
lesquels nous avons travaillé et
avec lesquels nous sommes allés
voir à l'étranger ce qu'avaient
fait notamment les pays européens.
Hier, le président de la
République a lancé l'acte 2 de
cette réflexion sur la fin de vie.
Il a souhaité ouvrir à
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
plutôt qu'à la fin de vie, avec la
volonté partagée et nécessaire
d'avancer vers les soins
palliatifs, et donc de travailler
à une stratégie décennale.
Cette stratégie s'articulera avec
l'obligation que nous avons
d'aller vers une égalité d'accès,
avec les EHPAD, avec les
établissements médico-sociaux,
mais aussi avec les soins
palliatifs.
Nous devrons le faire avec nos
concitoyens.
Il a aussi ouvert la porte à ce
que les 184 citoyens nous ont
demandé, avec le dépôt d'un projet
de loi qui sera co-construit avec
les parlementaires et des
soignants, sur une aide active à
mourir.
Nous devons aussi travailler sur
l'accompagnement du deuil.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Aymeric Caron.
- Aymeric Caron: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture, l'agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire a annoncé le
15 février l'interdiction d'un
herbicide très utilisé sur les
cultures de tournesol et de soja.
Un herbicide responsable d'une
vaste contamination des nappes
phréatiques françaises.
Cet herbicide est classé parmi les
produits cancérogènes suspectés
depuis juin 2022.
Ce produit est mauvais pour la
santé.
C'est donc une bonne chose que
d'en interdire son usage.
Selon un article récent du Monde,
en 2021, 12 millions de Français
de métropole ont reçu à leur
robinet une eau non conforme en
raison des pesticides.
Pourtant, vous venez de demander à
l'agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de revenir sur
l'interdiction de cet herbicide.
Cette demande nous paraît
hallucinante.
D'abord, qu'elle contrevient aux
objectifs affichés de réduction
des pesticides dans notre
agriculture.
Ensuite parce qu'elle dénonce un
insupportable mépris pour la santé
des Français.
Enfin parce qu'il s'agit d'une
inacceptable remise en cause de
l'indépendance de l'Anses.
Je mentirais si je disais que
votre position nous surprend.
Comme député, vous avez voté
contre l'interdiction du
glyphosate.
Comme ministre, vous avez voulu
prolonger les néonicotinoïdes.
Donc vous persistez dans votre
soutien à l'agriculture intensive
et au lobby agro-industriel.
D'ailleurs, votre demande de
maintien de l'herbicide en
question, vous l'avez fait lors du
congrès de la FNSEA, auquel vous
avez voulu faire plaisir une fois
de plus.
Les esprits un peu taquins ont
coutume de dire qu'en France,
c'est la FNSEA qui dirige.
Pouvez-vous nous prouver que ce
n'est pas le cas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Monsieur le député
Caron, avec le sens de la nuance
qui vous est mondialement reconnu,
vous me posez une question sur cet
herbicide.
On va vous redonner les objectifs
du gouvernement.
C'est la réduction de l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires.
Premier élément de la stratégie.
Une partie du chemin a été faite
puisque, sur certaines molécules,
on a déjà réduit de 80 à 85% les
usages.
Vous devriez regarder les choses
avec ce regard.
Le deuxième sujet, c'est d'agir au
niveau européen.
Troisième sujet, c'est d'essayer
de construire des alternatives.
Je sais que vous pensez que les
interdictions produisent des
solutions.
Moi, je pense qu'on a besoin de
construire ensemble des
alternatives et des solutions, ne
vous en déplaise.
On a besoin de travailler avec la
recherche sur ces éléments.
Quel crime ai-je commis?
J'ai interrogé simplement non pas
la décision de l'Anses, mais je me
suis demandé s'il n'y avait pas
lieu de se conformer à un
calendrier européen par souci de
cohérence.
Je sais que vous avez du mal avec
ces éléments.
J'ai simplement posé cette
question sans remettre du tout en
cause...
Lisez les courriers, monsieur
Caron.
Sans remettre en cause les
décisions de l'Anses.
Comme on était dans une cohérence
de calendrier, je me demandais
simplement s'il n'y avait pas lieu
d'interroger cette question sous
cet angle-là.
L'Anses donne un certain nombre de
mois pour sortir de cette
molécule.
C'est dire si cette question du
calendrier est cruciale.
Je sais que vous avez du mal à
vous poser des questions quand
vous posez des questions et à
nourrir des...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Hervé Saulignac.
- Hervé Saulignac: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Souveraineté industrielle et
numérique.
Je voudrais vous interroger sur la
montée en puissance de
l'intelligence artificielle.
Les évolutions des dernières
semaines sont particulièrement
impressionnante.
Une équipe de chercheurs de
Stanford a annoncé être en mesure
d'entraîner un modèle équivalent
au fameux ChatGPT 3 avec un budget
de seulement 600 dollars.
Plusieurs publications laissent
penser que nous approchons d'une
intelligence artificielle dite
"forte" c'est-à-dire capable de
comprendre toute tâche
intellectuelle qu'un être humain
peut accomplir.
Ces développements soulignent
l'importance de se doter d'une
stratégie nationale pour assurer
notre souveraineté et garantir que
la France soit compétitive sur la
scène internationale.
Ma question est la suivante:
existe-t-il une stratégie
gouvernementale pour faire face à
ces défis, notamment en matière
d'investissements, de recherche et
de formation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Merci.
Monsieur le député Hervé
Saulignac, vous avez raison de
dire qu'il y a dans l'intelligence
artificielle de grandes promesses
et de grands progrès.
Je pense en particulier aux
progrès de la recherche
scientifique, avec l'intelligence
artificielle qui sauve déjà des
vies en permettant de détecter des
cancers très précocement et donc
de les soigner, ou encore de
découvrir de manière plus
accélérée des traitements ou des
vaccins, comme ça a été le cas
pendant la Covid-19.
Pour que cette technologie reste
au service de l'humain et au
service des Français, il faut en
avoir la maîtrise, et il faut donc
créer un cadre de confiance dans
lequel ces innovations peuvent se
développer.
Pour en avoir la maîtrise, le
président de la République a lancé
en 2018 une stratégie nationale
pour l'intelligence artificielle,
éclairée par le rapport de Cédric
Villani, doté de 1,5 milliard
d'euros, qui a permis notamment la
création de quatre instituts
interdisciplinaires de
l'intelligence artificielle à
Nice, à Toulouse, à Grenoble et à
Paris, qui produisent aujourd'hui
des résultats.
Nous avons 500 doctorants de plus
qu'auparavant, 190 chaires
consacrées à l'intelligence
artificielle.
Nous avons doublé le nombre de
diplômés en intelligence
artificielle.
Nous avons 600 entreprises
innovantes spécialisées dans
l'intelligence artificielle.
Cette stratégie a été renouvelée
en 2021 dans le cadre de France
2030.
Nous veillons à ce qu'elle tienne
compte des dernières évolutions en
matière d'intelligence
artificielle.
Le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour qu'en matière
d'intelligence artificielle, la
France reste souveraine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Saulignac?
- Hervé Saulignac: Merci.
Vous venez de répondre au 578e
député, puisque cette question a
été entièrement rédigée par
ChatGPT.
Le robot qui vient de vous
interroger n'a pas soulevé de
question de liberté, de démocratie
ou de menace pour notre
civilisation.
Or les vrais sujets sont
précisément ceux que le robot
contourne.
Ne contournez pas les réponses,
monsieur le ministre.
C'est ce qui fait la différence
entre le robot et vous, parce
qu'il y a urgence.
La recherche est aux mains de
groupes privés qui n'ont aucun
intérêt à ralentir leur course
folle.
L'Union Européenne a un processus
législatif trop long et trop lent.
Il faut construire très vite une
autorité de régulation.
La France doit dire qu'elle ne
placera jamais son destin
technologique au-dessus de
considérations vitales et
universelles et que la société n'a
d'avenir que dans l'humanisme, la
liberté et la protection de sa
vulnérabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Il ne faut pas
perdre l'espoir dans
l'intelligence humaine.
J'avais anticipé la suite de votre
question.
L'Europe sera bientôt la première
démocratie du monde à installer un
cadre pour l'intelligence
artificielle qui dira les usages
pour lesquelles l'intelligence
artificielle est interdite, les
usages critiques pour lesquels
elle sera conditionnée à des
déclarations d'audit et les usages
pour lesquels elle sera autorisée.
Ce doit être un cadre de
confiance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Sylvain Maillard.
- Sylvain Maillard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
des Transports.
Les nouvelles mobilités sont au
coeur de la révolution des
transports au sein de nos villes.
Les trottinettes électriques ont
notamment connu un développement
exponentiel, avec aujourd'hui près
de 2,5 millions d'utilisateurs et
plus de 100.000 trajets par jour
en libre-service en France.
Un développement qui a pu paraître
bien souvent chaotique, comme nous
l'avons régulièrement dénoncé avec
mes collègues députés parisiens
Renaissance.
Pour autant, plutôt que d'assumer
son rôle de régulateur, la Ville
de Paris a organisé dimanche un
scrutin bancal autour d'une
question binaire, sans aucune
campagne officielle, pas de vote
en ligne ni de procuration, et
très peu de bureaux ouverts.
Le constat est là, avec seulement
7,4% de votants.
Ce scrutin est un fiasco.
Malgré tout, la maire de Paris ose
parler de victoire de la
démocratie.
C'est sûr que 91.000 personnes
ayant voté contre, c'est toujours
plus que les 23.000 Parisiens
ayant voté pour elle à l'élection
présidentielle.
Je pense aux jeunes parisiens qui
sont les grands perdants de cette
votation qui a décidé d'opposer
une génération à une autre.
C'est une défaite de la politique
de la ville.
Les trottinettes électriques
resteront autorisées mais ne
seront donc accessibles qu'à ceux
qui ont les moyens d'en acheter
une.
A la réflexion, ce sont tous les
Parisiens, les perdants!
Non seulement ils ne pourront plus
utiliser les trottinettes en
libre-service, mais en plus ils
gardent Anne Hidalgo comme maire.
Quels sont les grands axes de
votre politique pour mieux réguler
ces nouvelles mobilités sans les
interdire purement et simplement,
comme on l'a vu à Paris?
Car c'est ça qui doit nous guider:
réguler mais toujours laisser de
la liberté, pour le plus grand
bénéfice des usagers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Monsieur le
député Maillard, comme vous, je
regrette que la Ville de Paris
s'enferme sur ce sujet.
C'est un échec populaire.
Quand 7,4% des électeurs se
déplacent, on ne peut pas vraiment
parler de triomphe populaire, sauf
à être dans une réalité parallèle.
C'est un échec sur le fond
également, parce que la même ville
qui a déployé 15.000 trottinettes
en libre-service fait endosser son
échec aux Parisiens eux-mêmes.
Cet échec me préoccupe en vue des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques,
puisque nous avons besoin de
solliciter tous nos modes de
transport.
Nous n'avons le luxe d'en exclure
aucun.
Nous manquons déjà à Paris et en
Ile-de-France de vélos en
libre-service.
Nous aurions eu besoin de ces
15.000 engins électriques et donc
écologiques.
C'est d'autant plus dommageable
que, par ailleurs, ce ne sont pas
les trottinettes qui sont
interdites, ce sont les
trottinettes en libre-service, et
les trottinettes privées, plus
coûteuses, moins protectrices et
moins régulées seront toujours
disponibles et pulluleront dans
nos villes.
J'ai donc présenté un plan
d'action pour aider les
collectivités à mieux les réguler.
L'immense majorité des villes de
France ont aujourd'hui des
trottinettes en libre-service,
plus de 200.
Elles savent les réguler.
Ce sont des villes de toutes
sensibilités politiques, y compris
des villes écologistes.
Par ce plan d'action nationale,
j'ai décidé de renforcer ces
mesures en relevant l'âge minimum
d'utilisation de 12 à 14 ans.
Nous allons relever le niveau des
contraventions.
On va obliger les opérateurs à
prendre des engagements
écologiques, à vérifier
précisément l'âge d'utilisation.
Nous pouvons, en toute
responsabilité, comme le font
l'immense majorité des villes de
France, avancer, protéger et
réguler.
C'est ce qu'on doit faire quand on
est responsable politique, et je
continuerai.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Sabrina Sebaihi.
- Sabrina Sebaihi: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à Olivier
Dussopt.
Chez plusieurs de nos voisins
européens, l'heure est à la
réduction du temps de travail, car
c'est le sens de l'histoire.
Que ce soit l'Islande, le
Royaume-Uni, la Belgique ou encore
l'Espagne, tous ces pays ont mis
en place ou ont testé avec succès
la semaine de quatre jours.
Le magazine Forbes, qui peut
difficilement être qualifié d'un
magazine d'extrême gauche,
qualifie même l'expérimentation de
la semaine de quatre jours au
Royaume-Uni de "réussite".
Vous assumez aujourd'hui donc
d'aller à contresens de
l'histoire, avec une réforme des
retraites purement paramétrique,
qui va pénaliser les travailleurs
les plus en difficulté et les
femmes, quand vous auriez pu faire
le choix de mettre à contribution
les plus aisés.
Depuis des semaines, vous avez
contourné les débats, en utilisant
toutes les procédures empêchant
les parlementaires d'examiner ce
texte convenablement, jusqu'à
l'ultime 49.3, face à votre peur
de perdre le vote final à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Aujourd'hui, la grande majorité
des Français, de toutes les
classes d'âge interrogées, sont
très clairs et ils vous disent que
le pays n'est pas prêt à passer à
autre chose comme si de rien
n'était.
La réalité, c'est que ce
gouvernement a réussi à faire
d'une crise sociale une crise
politique, une crise de régime,
car la légitimité morale et
sociale, vous ne l'avez plus.
Une république sociale, comme la
nôtre, elle ne peut s'obtenir
contre le peuple.
Votre entêtement à faire passer
cette réforme, j'oserais dire
"quoi qu'il en coûte", contre
l'avis des économistes, contre
l'intersyndicale, contre les
parlementaires, contre les
Français, a déclenché une
mobilisation sociale massive, la
plus forte depuis des décennies,
menant le pays à l'impasse.
Ma question est la suivante:
pensez-vous que l'on peut
gouverner contre la majorité des
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, vous avez évoqué la
question du temps de travail.
Vous considérez qu'en matière de
travail, la logique voudrait que
nous puissions aller vers une
diminution de celui-ci.
Le gouvernement n'envisage pas de
revenir sur le temps de travail
légal, ni dans un sens ni dans
l'autre.
Nous considérons que l'aménagement
du temps de travail permet de
fixer un cadre.
On peut bénéficier d'une
rémunération exonérée d'impôts
depuis 2017 au-delà du temps de
travail légal.
Cela constitue un cadre qu'il faut
préserver.
Vous dites que de nombreux pays en
Europe ont mis en oeuvre une
réduction du temps de travail.
Ils ne sont pas encore au niveau
de la France.
Nous sommes le deuxième pays
européen où nous travaillons le
moins.
Le temps de travail effectif en
France en 2019 à -- est à 1680
heures, quand il est à 1850 en
moyenne dans toute l'Europe.
Il n'y a qu'en Suède que le temps
de travail moyen est inférieur à
celui que nous connaissons en
France.
Nous avons là une différence
d'appréciation.
Une des réponses à apporter au
déficit de notre système de
retraite, c'est être plus nombreux
à travailler et aussi de
travailler plus à l'échelle d'une
vie.
Nous considérons simplement que,
pour qu'il y ait redistribution,
il faut qu'il y ait production.
Il n'est pas possible de financer
un modèle social si nous ne
produisons pas des richesses.
Nous devons collectivement
travailler plus.
Ca n'est pas nécessairement
travailler plus longtemps par
semaine.
Travailler plus longtemps à
l'échelle d'une vie.
C'est surtout travailler plus
nombreux pour faire en sorte que
ce système soit mieux équilibré.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous avez cinq
secondes.
- Sabrina Sebaihi: Vous indiquez
ne pas toucher au temps de
travail.
Or, vous passez à 43 ans de
cotisations et vous ajoutez deux
ans de temps de travail pour les
Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christelle d'Intorni.
- Christelle d'Intorni: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
Depuis la parution du livre "Les
fossoyeurs" qui a révélé une
insupportable maltraitance sur nos
aînés, le groupe Orpea est dans la
tourmente.
Cette entreprise cotée en bourse,
dramatiquement endettée, va
restructurer son capital et sa
dette.
Cette entreprise privée, à
capitaux privés, à endettement
privé, va pourtant faire appel à
de l'argent public pour se
financer à nouveau au détriment de
ses actionnaires et de ses
créanciers.
Comment?
En détournant les dispositions de
la nouvelle loi de sauvegarde.
En amont de la restructuration,
Orpea a créé un déséquilibre entre
les créanciers, afin de sécuriser
uniquement les dettes des banques
françaises.
Cela lui a permis de créer une
classe de créanciers privilégiés
et ainsi de s'affranchir
définitivement des droits de vote
des petits actionnaires et
créanciers non sécurisés qui
détiennent pourtant 85% du capital
de la société.
La triste réalité, c'est que la
Caisse des Dépôts, qui n'est pas
actionnaire, va pouvoir acheter
50,2% des titres d'Orpea à moins
de 3% du prix du cours, et 70%
moins cher que les actionnaires
qui ont pourtant le droit de
souscription privilégié.
Tout cela sans tenir la moindre
assemblée générale.
Cautionnez-vous ce montage qui
spolie les actionnaires et
créanciers d'Orpea de leur
patrimoine au profit de la Caisse
des Dépôts?
Acceptez-vous que la Caisse des
Dépôts s'arroge plus de 50% du
capital d'une entreprise cotée en
bourse à Paris sans lancer d'OPA?
Avez-vous conscience que ce
montage contestable va affecter le
marché de la dette française?
Enfin, tolérez-vous qu'aucune
assemblée générale ne soit
convoquée afin de permettre aux
millions de petits porteurs qui
détiennent véritablement Orpea de
s'exprimer?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Geneviève Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Madame
la députée d'Intorni, je ne suis
pas ministre de l'Economie et je
ne suis pas non plus
Jean-Christophe Combe, qui est en
charge des travaux du CNR bien
vieillir aujourd'hui.
Mais je vais tâcher de vous
répondre, peut-être pas sur les
petits porteurs, mais sur la
philosophie générale du problème
Orpea.
Orpea a créé une grande défiance
pour les familles, pour les
personnes âgées que l'on avait
dans les structures d'Orpea.
Il fallait redonner de la
confiance.
Cela passait par des
transformations actionnariales,
qui ont été faites sous l'égide de
la Caisse des Dépôts, qui font en
sorte que, désormais, l'Etat a un
droit de regard.
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un nous
reprochera d'avoir ce droit de
regard, alors que nous avons connu
ce scandale qui a véritablement
créé un électrochoc dans notre
société.
J'ai entendu votre question,
madame.
Je voulais vous dire qu'il fallait
bien sûr rassurer les Français
ainsi que les familles, les
personnes âgées et redonner de la
confiance dans nos EHPAD.
L'effort
d'actionnariat d'Etat a participé
en faisant en sorte que la Caisse
des Dépôts, des mutuelles et des
assurances puissent reprendre
l'actionnariat d'Orpea.
L'actionnariat avait beaucoup
chuté de façon brutale, mettant en
grand danger les structures et les
personnels qui travaillaient à
l'intérieur d'Orpea.
Nous allons poursuivre cette
action, comme nous allons
poursuivre l'action de contrôle de
ces structures, de tous les EHPAD,
qui est en oeuvre aujourd'hui et
dont nous aurons les résultats
d'ici 2024.
Ces contrôles et ces évolutions de
l'actionnariat permettront d'avoir
une confiance plus importante des
Français dans leur système de
prise en charge des personnes en
situation de handicap.
- Christelle d'Intorni: Je suis
désolée, mais vous n'avez rassuré
personne puisque vous n'avez
absolument pas répondu à ma
question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance des
questions au gouvernement est
terminée.
La séance est suspendue.